it's the first safe transit point for
those fleeing shelling and airstrikes a
parking lot
outside a shopping mall
aptly named epicenter
all day long convoys of cars kept
arriving this one was the first of the
day
olena gilbert was born in russia she
could have left her home town of
mariupol earlier but she didn't
all my relatives live in russia
they are worried about me they ask me to
go there
i love them but i won't be able to go i
won't stand it
when you are bombed how can you forgive
there was the possibility to go to
russia there are three buses daily that
go to donetsk but many people want to go
to ukraine and they don't know how
throughout the day they just kept on
arriving mostly fleeing places like her
son melitopol berdians and other places
under russian control
some were on their last legs
the u.n convoy with the civilians
evacuated from the azov style steel
factory is also supposed to arrive here
but just as
those who made it out are going through
thorough security checks by the
ukrainians those on board the buses are
being vetted by the russians
under the safe passage agreement
brokered by the un
only women children and the elderly are
allowed to leave about a hundred
civilians were rescued from the steel
works they have been sheltering in
tunnels and bunkers underneath the
soviet era factory
pale and exhausted they crawled out of
the rubble
we need to carry out some sort of
special operation because people are
under the rubble we hear them talking
but we can't lift the slabs we wanted to
clear the rubble outside the bunkers
that blocked the entrance but we can't
because of the shelling
the convoy is on the move but as olena
moscienko says driving out of mariopol
involves several hurdles
they kept us forever at the checkpoints
at the last checkpoint they pushed us
back and told us to come at 7am with a
promise that we will cross they let us
through the convoy was huge there were a
lot of people but only 25 cars made it
the rest were turned back a russian
soldier was shooting in the air he
warned us that next time he will shoot
to kill
russia wants to make sure soldiers hold
up at the factory don't sneak out among
the civilians
for those who make it
these are difficult but joyful moments
but to those still trapped in mariupol
these are dark hours where the end is
difficult to predict
al jazeera zapurija